[Musique]
aujourd'hui il ya le temps bonjour géré
la sombre bonjour mobile c'est à tous
les auditeurs de martine première mais
on veut à tous ou 2017 président du
comité régional olympique et sportif de
martinique 2010 cette nouvelle année
jamais son beau avec quelle échéance
pour l'autre ville pour notre île au
plan sportif d'abord ce que les élus de
la ctm voudront bien avoir comme vision
du secteur à travers à travers ce fameux
livre blanc bien hâte encore un peu bon
il ya eu les assises c'est vrai un petit
peu précipité mais en tout cas il ya eu
des réflexions et dd je dirais des
remontées intéressante et effectivement
nous nous et nous espérons avoir une
synthèse
en tout cas nous nous sommes on marche
un projet sans industrie dans laquelle
sur lequel nous a été du 4 ans et nous
sommes en mars y eut beaucoup de mesures
de réflexion qui ont été évoqués nous
sommes en développement déjà double
projet sauvé du style au niveau du
causse manquera vraiment de ce livre
blanc on rappelle il ya eu les assises
au mois de juin juillet les objectifs
étant de définir les orientations
stratégiques de la politique publique
sportif de la ctm un grand finir
financeur du sport martiniquais est ce
que le sport peut pas se faire sans les
politiques a pas du tout ce que je
voudrais dire d'emblée pour les clés
même si un peu de retard le président
marie jeanne est très favorable au spo
vous le savez les dispositifs des
dirigeants donc nous avons d'ailleurs
j'ai directement de contact avec lui
pour certains dossiers et par conséquent
il ya une volonté réelle de 2 d'asseoir
et chose d'intéressant
maintenant il faut effectivement que ces
temps de réflexion se termine et qu'on
puisse mettre en place vraiment des
mesures politiques publiques comme je le
disais nous sommes nous déjà en marche
avec notre projet sur une liste alors il
ya des finances publiques effectivement
il ya le monde de l'entreprise le monde
de l'économie martiniquaise à ce que ce
que les entreprises locales de la
martinique ont envie de vialer
franchement dans le milieu sportif
encore plus oui je pense que c'est
voulons il ya une volonté ferme puisque
nous avons une convention avec le medef
nous avons créé mêmes fins dotation que
nous souhaitons mettre en oeuvre en 2010
est donc maintenant il ya cette volonté
mais il faut organiser les choses il
faut que je dirais sur le plan de la
communication sportive le plan de même
jeudi le marketing mais même avec les
antennes des radios et télévisions qui
est une une organisation du de la
communication dans quelques disciplines
pour quelques sportifs ou bien trop
l'ensemble du spar martinique l'ensemble
nous sommes à la veille de créer une
oeuvre créée l'association pour sciences
po c'est une association qui devrait
accompagner l'aîné sport les dirigeants
sportifs dans le domaine
je dirais sociale et le domaine
administratif c'est à dire fiche de
salaire contre travail mais aussi
peut-être une extension sur
l'accompagnement en termes de
communication
chacun n'a pas forcément le temps de
soigner sa communication c'est un métier
et par conséquent moi je crois en la
participation du monde privée mais avec
aussi ce soin cette amélioration sur la
qualité de la communication des ligues
des dirigeants qui n'ont pas forcément
ni la science ni notre temps de s'en
occuper
ce sont des bras on attend la
désignation du pays qui accueillera les
jeux olympiques de 2024 géré mais son
beau ce sera le 13 septembre de cette
année le cross med et fabien défend bien
entendu la candidature de paris avec de
sérieuses carte à jouer auprès des pays
de la région caraïbe tout à fait bien de
petites anecdotes en 2009 avant quand il
y avait une compétition entre paris et
londres
rapidement nous avait appelés fait appel
à vos comme copenhague aille pour nous
aider mais c'était un petit peu je
dirais sans fondement puisque nous
n'avions pas à l'époque une appartient
n'est qu'une relation officielle
aujourd'hui nous sommes à mille après
xisan le travail comme membre associé de
la caq sceaux entend des parcs axe au
centre américain en cabine sport
organisation ça fait 60 pays
c'est la première fois que nous sommes
historiquement qualifier pour les jeux
continentaux olympique qui se font à
deux jours tous les quatre à deux ans
des cas des jeux olympiques donc c'est
des jeux qui existent 226 donc sommes
très fiers en 2018 de pouvoir j'espère
amener une délégation à barran qu'il a
et à cg de la caso et par conséquent
nous sommes aujourd'hui impliquer
pleinement dans les assemblées le 3
février prochain une semaine ça semblait
internationales importantes et le
président masseglia président du comité
olympique français souhaitent nous
accompagner parce que évidemment il nous
a confié ce rôle de deux ambassadeurs du
sport nous avons traîné là mamadou n'est
pas tout à fait de même mais ça devrait
se faire et par conséquent nous sommes
les trois départements français est
présent dans 7 ce concert est bien dû
cependant un peu géopolitique aussi et
nous avons effectivement une influence
certaine puisque certains membres de ces
associations internationales aux membres
du cio ils vont voter pour la
candidature de paris
le président masseglia nous a clairement
signifié le rôle que nous avions à ce
niveau ou défend la candidature de paris
d'où il est vrai les pressions que les
pays de la zone caraïbe vont tendre
davantage fort de france pointe à pitre
cayenne que paris directement
moi je pense que oui parce que nous
sommes nous avons été acceptée même s'il
ya eu des procédures au niveau de la
caraïbe très vite et au niveau de
l'amérique centrale
il ya eu quelques négociations
juridiques parce qu'il fallait établir
les régiments ces poussières deal qui
viennent qu'ils sont pas franchement
indépendante et qui viennent avec rio
vous que dans le rail a beaucoup de
statuts différents poteaux icônes et de
tétouan à mékhé autonome et a une
autonomie sportive complète les îles vie
elles sont citoyens
mitrani quoi beenkens aux citoyens
américains britanniques pourtant une
zone d'où certaines tombes il ya
différents statuts de la grippe nous
nous sommes nous avons accueillis comme
des frais encore idée et je dois le dire
même s'il fallait passer par des
procédures longues
il a fallu du temps parce que comité
directeur assemblée générale
internationale
il fallait aussi conditions juridiques
parce que ça nous ouvre la pensée
passion jeu aujourd'hui à des conditions
intéressantes de participation génie
réalité gernay son beau la réalité des
médailles
nos pays ramène des médailles à la
france et ça ils le savent bien aux jeux
de rio c'est clair 42 médailles 17
d'outre-mer dont 5 chez nous avec les
périodes fixes et frais 7
ils ont été affichées au kosma j'espère
les affiches et d'un nouveau pont parce
que ce sont nous idole je voudrais pas
que des à barbade à trinidad a jamais
qu'ils le savent ça il le savait on sait
le résultat est aujourd'hui je crois qu
il est très important de signaler le mée
plication du du sport guyanais dans les
résultats français ce qui d'ailleurs a
même pas mal digérée je dirais moi je
suis militant disant que nous apportons
trop à oslo international où tous ports
français pour ne pas voir au tout je
demande un certain nombre de mesures fox
culturelles notamment termes
d'équipement avaient justement nous
avions reçu patrick anr le ministre des
sports qui ici dans ce studio avait
promis le coeur sur la main jallet son
beau qu'une enveloppe de 80 millions sur
quatre ans aurait été débloqué pour
l'ensemble des autres maires pour un
plan de développement des équipements
sportifs chez nous at on vu l'ombre de
2000 centimes pour nos équipements ici
en martinique alors sans présager de
l'avenir ou de durée de la vie politique
vous savez comment des chaussons part du
mot difficile résidentiel fonctionnement
un programme le camion évidemment v
millions par an mais sur l'ensemble de
l'outre-mer
ce qui résume un sexe est mignon pour la
martinique environ dont cet homme de
dossiers déjà prêts sont remontés dont
j'avais propose pas pour positionner
d'ailleurs blockhaus la maison du sport
qui est pour l'instant discussion
parce que c'est un instrument qui mérite
d'être rénovée avec 30 ans ne manquer
aucune indiscrétion jamais son beau que
c'était une promesse électoraliste tout
simplement parce que les échéances
présidentielles arrivait bon je pense
que patrick nerfs il ya un peu de ça
aussi il faut pas faut pas être je
dirais dupe ce ça fait bien longtemps
que nous contribuons est justement
debout tellement ce plan arrive
certainement je veux bien quoi je lui ai
bien joué le jeu sur -7 cossette
contribution donc nous allons nous
battre puisque les dossiers sont
remontés par la jeunesse et sports et
par le préfet comme il y en a trop bien
à peu près ici pour fort de france alors
il y avait quand même près de 60
demandes qu'avance aigre été obtenues et
puis je ne sais pas quand exactement ça
vous monte sur le bio nuit puisque
évidemment ça il y aura une sélection
assez drastique puisque l'enveloppé
n'est pas extensible à 5 millions malgré
tout avec des dossiers structurants vous
pensez bien que ça va très vite et que
ça va être je dirais plus significatives
autre chose moi j'appelle au lieu de la
précipitation thomas ne contestera un
plan quinquennal réfléchit à long terme
qui soit vraiment plan de rattrapage au
vu je disais des résultats de
l'outre-mer et les antis antilles
lyonnais donne depuis tant d'années
comme résultat j'appelle vraiment plan
sérieux structure et puis une
organisation locale aussi de l'urbanisme
sportif qui n'est un petit peu mon avis
hasardeuse amélie type de structuration
par des assistants be to do vale temps
des ingénieurs qui pense et nous avons
le personnel pour cela nous avons les
sacripants sera totalement nous sommes
en négociation que là c'était justement
il jeux dispo mettre en place une réelle
type de travail pour prévoit faire des
prévisions parce qu'ils ne savaient
c'est le livre blanc ça ça peut être en
iec les librement ce que les instruments
et d'équipements voulait prévoyez vous
trompe 30 50 ans à venir donc il faut
avoir une projection un plan 2 de
développement pour asseoir guillemant
mais je veux dire par là que la notion
d' équipements répondent souvent
l'opportunité open le contexte de
communes ou de vous de politique il faut
sortir de cette ce contexte uniquement
politique parce que c'est malgré tout
les maires qui accueille des essais
d'équipements
il faut donc aussi les écouter leurs
besoins mais fou que ça dansait dans une
mairie qui ont de moins en moins ce
d'argent qui se tournent maintenant vers
les communautés d'agglomération
qui est aussi un n'ont pas beaucoup
d'argent c'est clair c'est la crise et
c'est difficile donc d'où l'idée qu'il
faut penser à mon avis à des équipements
de proximité des équipements
je pense aux os peau de plage pense
aussi aux équipements de quartier qui
pot qu'on pourrait réhabiliter parce que
nous avons surtout besoin non pas de
gomme cathédrale mais de multiples
instruments dans les quartiers pour que
notre jeunesse soient occupés et inclut
de la dynamique du spo qui est
formatrice et kg et qu'il faut lui
demander d'éducation jamais son bourreau
peut-on financer tous les équipements
sportifs pour toutes les disciplines ne
faut-il pas faire des choix par exemple
vers martigny quand on va se baser
essentiellement par exemple sur une
demi-douzaine d'une demi douzaine de
disciplines et pas le reste parce qu'on
n'a pas les moyens tout faire ça va de
soi même des toujours difficile
d'imposer un quota ne favorise une
activité pas aux bonnes notes sa réponse
n est qu une logique de marché là où il
ya beaucoup de pratiquants il faut à mon
avis faire un effort particulier par
rapport à d'autres on peut raisonner ces
grandes ont par exemple on n'a peut-être
pas beaucoup de licenciés dans la des
champions exactement donc les cas de
figure sont différents il faut les
analyser au foot ils les moyens sauvé
lui donc il faut faire des choix et
faire c'est certain mais il faut pas non
plus aller dans la logique de je dirais
de sélectionne discipline qui serait
farba ce qu'elles sont soit nombreuses
massive ou plus expressément toi là je
crois qu'il faut tenir compte de ménager
la chèvre et le chou est arrivé à faire
quand même
malgré tout un plan et équitable la
reconversion des sportifs de haut niveau
pour l'avoir rencontré quelques-uns de
ceux qui ont porté les couleurs de la
france en état d'origine martiniquaise
qui reviennent au pays après avoir donné
j'ai beaucoup de sacrifice qu'est ce
qu'on peut dire là-dessus irmak beaucoup
qui sont ridicules et gris contrarier
absolument clair là dessus moi je moi je
pense qu'il doit tout faire parce que je
suis très déçu je suis militant dos ci
dessus beaucoup de nos athlètes qui
représentait la france et qui ont été
sept fois champion olympique champion du
monde sont là à végéter à l'eau qui a
rien prévu nous accueillons volontiers
des étrangers à l'extérieur avec
des attentions particulières et nos
propres athlètes nounou crachant sur
nous mêmes c'est dommage et je crois
qu'il faut vraiment changer cela déjà
par l'estimé et la considération qu'on
leur accorde et deuxièmement par le fait
qu'on puisse préparer cette nombreux
convient sans quoi la reconversion des
sportifs de haut niveau c'est donner un
travail de secrétariat par exemple au
sein d'une ligue a payé au smic ou après
avoir été sous les projecteurs mais il
faut réfléchir parce que évidemment on
ne peut pas donner un métier uniquement
parce qu'on était sportif aussi que
l'incompétence donc mais moi je pense
qu'on peut former nous appeler certaines
disciplines où les acteurs qu'il ait
rencontré ces sportifs de haut niveau
moi j'ai une expérience douloureuse à
décrire
moi je suis très très dame est à bout
deux athlètes qui ont été en moi au
départ un formidable quand j'étais
moi-même jeune j'étais à l'insep j'étais
un peu en équipe de france et je me
rappelle voyais un de deux de mes petits
jets de 16 ans je voyais ma sultan qui
joue du prof d'éducation physique mais
qui a été accueilli à mon sens pas comme
il faudrait alors qu'elle était vraiment
la marine bull
une des premières reine du sprint et c
est au niveau du foot je prendrai
l'exemple de gérard janvion quitté la
gare de noir s'étaient c'est que c'est
une personnalité à clermont ferrand même
évité dans les grandes manifestations
hier à man latéraux qui montent et
gérard j'ai eu à discuter cnjs et c'est
vraiment dommage il s'est mis un petit
peu d'hollande mais c'est vraiment
dommage que comme une telle ou telle
personnalité n'est pas été je dirais mis
en lumière épépinez pas pu porter la
contribution qui méritait pas trop tard
évidemment mais voilà ce que je pense
qu'il faudrait vraiment changer ça merci
d'avoir été ce matin avec n'ont jamais
son bord quelque chose est le président
du crosa comité régional olympique et
sportif de la martinique